uh i've got something very important in
my hand right here
what uh you know what this is pass the
lead leave early no
i i no contract raised no
these are these are the uh finalists
for the six individual nba regular
season awards and we're going to
announce the finalists
let's do it ernest hey and get your get
your thoughts on
on who you think uh should walk away
with these so let's begin with
the kia nba rookie of the year so here
are the three finalists john morant
kendrick nunn zion williamson
is there a question draymond green in
your mind as to who the rookie of the
year is
no question at all i think john marant
he's played well all year
and you know he has memphis sitting in
the a spot right now
obviously if zion was healthy he'd
probably be rookie of the year with the
numbers he's putting up but you got to
go with john marant
and shout out to kendrick nunn he's had
a great year he's got a nice move
jaw 18 points four rebounds seven
assists shooting 48
percent what do you think i think it's
in that order too you know i don't know
because
you know zion didn't play if he didn't
if he played he's like he like yeah he's
23 games now he played 19 he had played
19 games at the time
23 games he showed that he's better than
most rookies
and and he's not a rookie but i think
kendrick nunn
uh john murray kinder uh and zion in
that order yeah i think just because of
the mounted games but zion has
would have he would have won the award
the numbers he putting up if he would
have played the whole season
well number one i think both of you guys
correct uh i think it's easily
jaw and i do think kendrick is a second
the new orleans pelicans
got to make a decision soon on on zion
like the best ability is availability
that's like we've been saying that in
sports for 100 years
they're gonna have to figure out his
body they're gonna have to figure out
his weight
that's what they got to do this off
season because they can't
not first of all you can't get in
basketball sheep not playing basketball
and you need to know if he can stay
healthy
that's a really big deal like i said he
seems like a great kid
i'm pulling for him and i'm gonna give
him some advice and i don't know this
i told you the best person ever happened
to me in my life basketball wise was
moses malone
and he said to me chuck you're fat and
you're lazy i say that every day
on my fault nothing's changed just
channeling your inner moses
but you know ernie i did not know i
could lose 50 pounds
when he told me that he says charles
let's lose 10 pounds at a time
and i went from 293 to 250.
i didn't know i could lose 50 pounds now
i'm not saying like but they got to sit
down with zion and say
what weight can you play at and be
explosive
and be strong because if you don't you
can't help us
plan 20 minutes a night or not playing
80 games you can't do that let's move on
to the mvp finalists and uh
so you got giannis the reigning mvp
third in scoring second in rebounds
team has the best record in the nba
james harden
he'll have his third straight scoring
title he's having he's averaging 34. and
lebron james 25
8 and 10 leading the league in assists
in his 17th season at the age of
35. there was certainly some buzz
late in the season before the before the
hiatus uh hey lebron is making this a
race
with giannis um who's your mvp
chuck you honest easily lebron came in a
close second probably
listen they were on pace to win 70 games
they got the best
offense best defense you said something
to ernie
he's going to probably be the defensive
player of the year
listen i love lebron he's a great player
and a great man more than anything
great man but you threw something out
there ernie
why you have to tell us he's 35 i'm
watching these tv shows
hey he's playing great but they're like
well he's 35.
well okay he is he's amazing at 35 but
they got the best record in the nba they
were in
the pace to win 70 games in my opinion
is giannis
let's go to draymond please um
i'm going with lebron i think the year
lebron has had
and you know resurrecting that lakers
franchise i think that's
that has to stand for something so i'm
going with lebron but i have a question
does james harden get penalized
for the numbers that he's putting up now
like is everybody just used to it and
that's what you expect
and so now no one kind of gives him the
credit that he's deserving
i think i see a little bit of that i
think i think you right on james
his ability to get to the rim make play
you know what i'm most impressed about
him honestly draymond
is he had the reputation that he
wouldn't defend for about a year or two
before the mvp all of a sudden now 10
years
and then now honestly he
he makes a very conservative effort that
and he takes challenges defensively that
i haven't seen him take so
i do think that he he no i i think
there's a difference between taking a
challenge or guarding your man
hey let me ask you a question he's third
he's second to third no no second third
but second or third
behind janice lebron what do you mean no
listen listen
does he get he third on the list no no
no no but the question was do we look by
him no
he's throwing it on the list he just put
him there it's not we didn't put him
there he earned that there
i just said his name never comes up and
no no listen kenny you all laughed at me
everybody laughed at me a couple years
when i go i said this guy
is the best offensive player he's not a
greater player as michael jordan or kobe
bryant
but this guy here may be the greatest
offensive player
we've ever had because as great as
michael and kobe were
they weren't three-point shooters this
guy is a better three people
to get 81 in the game he
i think i think james harden could get
80 in the game if he would if he went
out just said i'm just going to get 80.
so we're all agreeing on the same thing
i think well i'm just saying you act
like we said he was like the seventh
best player but does james score like
that
back then when y'all were playing and
fouls weren't called the same way
they're called today
i did use that caveat in today's game
he's the greatest scorer
i've ever seen uh yeah it's a different
game it's a different game but but i
said
that he's the best we got offensively
today
we do know this we do know this that
whoever wins that will be saying that
they have won it
again so it's giannis and hardin barney
lebron
what you asking us who you think should
be mvp i had uh
giannis okay kevin durant's the best
scorer by the way and i had jaw
oh no kevin the best scorer ever
not even close in this in this era not
no disrespect to james but kevin durant
is the best scorer ever
all right let's move on that's a fair
cut that's a fair i don't agree with you
this is right up draymond's alley the
defensive player of the year giannis
can you win one of these draymond yes
sir i should have won
rudy gobert uh this is always one of
those like how do you quantify who's
the defensive player of the year what
makes a great defensive player
i think what makes a great defensive
player is someone who can be on the
floor at all times
who's never a liability on the floor and
so
for my defensive player of the year i
got to go with a.d i think he came out
in the beginning of the year and said i
want to be the defensive player of the
year
and he's backed that up he's blocked
shots he guards guards
he's really held the paint down for for
the lakers and you know obviously
they've played two bigs but what a deep
been able to do
inside and outside he's got to be the
defensive player of the year in my
opinion kenny
oh
you're i might go with giannis
anthony davis i just think that it's
apples and oranges is all fruit
but i i think because
the way giannis defends the perimeter
and the interior
this year you know there he is on the
interior
but then he would he will guard your
point guard
and rip your point guard there he is
he's ripping
hard away on a dribble on a crossover
dribble
so his abilities look like like hard way
can dribble
oh yeah come on man he can shoot the
lights out but
hey he's still a guard and his daddy
could dribble so he could dribble
whoa so i just think that he
i i would give it either one of them i
think rudy
kind of was a is a is third but
i would go with giannis just because of
his ability to play the perimeter this
year well
and i won't go with you kenny because i
think the ability there's not a player
he can't guard i mean he can guard a
center if he had to because he's big
enough
but like he can guard one two three
fours and five
uh listen rudy gobert is a great shot
blocker
anthony uh davis is a really good rim
protector
but i don't know if they could guard a
three or uh or two or three
yeah and janice can i i had giannis also
winning defensive player of the year
along with mvp
best defensive player on the best
defensive team in the nba what other
players done that ernie
best defensive player on the bench
uh most improved player finalists who
you got spam out of bayou
fam out of mario i agree bam out of
bikes who i had as well
uh sixth man of the year montrez
i'm going on montreal i had montrez lou
will
you know the underground goat i think
we're taking uh lou wings
for granted and but i'm gonna go with
montreal's harold
i'll go manchester but schroder's had a
terrific coach of the year coach of the
year oh that's not even close i had nick
nurse good good call ernie
hey bo uh buddenholzer did a good job
billy donovan did a good job
but what nick nurse has done this year
has been amazing
nick nurse for sure jett nick nurse okay
wow yeah see we got it done way to work
y'all